our main story tonight
concerns the fact that last weekend ruth
bader ginsburg died which was
distressing enough but it's been
compounded by the fact that just
yesterday
this happened good evening we begin with
breaking news the president nominating
amy coney barrett to the supreme court
barrett is a favorite of religious
conservatives for her strong
anti-abortion rights views
and if confirmed would move the court to
the right for a generation
right trump is about to replace a
liberal icon with an extremely
conservative justice who's been called
the female antonin scalia and she could
serve for a long time
amy coney barrett is only 48 and i know
that i make 43 look like 76 but trust me
that is young for a supreme court
justice and look if
and almost certainly when barrett is
confirmed to the supreme court the
impact
could be dire in recent years key cases
have been decided by just one vote from
upholding the affordable care act to
preserving daca to striking down an
incredibly restrictive abortion law
should those issues come before the
court again they could now easily go the
other way and there is clearly
no point holding on to hope that
conservatives might choose to respect
the president they set
by refusing to even consider merrick
garland in an election year because
that was always in bad faith as was
obvious at the time in fact
ahead of the 2016 election senator
richard burr
even privately said this to a group of
campaign volunteers
if hillary clinton becomes president
i'm going to do everything i can do to
make sure that
four years from now we've still got an
opening on the supreme court
yeah that's a republican senator
committing to blocking a justice
confirmation not just
in an election year but for an entire
presidential term
and just think about how long four years
is four years ago
harvey weinstein was still producing
movies in the past four years
harry and megan began dating got engaged
got married left the royal family and i
think own netflix now
and in the past four years leonardo
dicaprio's girlfriend gains the right to
legally drink
alcohol two more years and she'll have
no problem getting a rental car
to move her belongings out of his house
time is amazing
and some republicans seem to rationalize
their party's blatant hypocrisy by
saying that
should they confirm trump's nominee
they'll simply be bringing the court
closer to the will of the country
i recognize that we we may have a court
which has more of a
conservative bent than it's had over the
last few decades
but my liberal friends have over many
decades gotten very used to the idea of
having a liberal court
and that's not written in the stars it's
also appropriate for nation which is
if you will center right uh to have a
court which reflects a center-right
points of view
what the hell are you talking about mitt
set aside the notion that a court that
gutted the voting rights act is a
liberal court
since when is this nation naturally
center-right
did we all take a buzzfeed quiz that i'm
not remembering like choose your
favorite fall lasagna ingredients and
we'll tell you which direction the
nation's electorate leans
because for the record more americans
say they align with the democratic party
than the republicans plus
poll after poll has shown americans
favor abortion rights with
support of roe v wade reaching record
highs while a strong majority of the
public
also supports medicare for all oh and
incidentally
a solid majority say the winner of this
presidential election should be the one
to choose ginsburg's successor so
our country isn't so much center-right
as mitt romney is
center wrong look this has been a very
dark week for a lot of people
the supreme court is about to lurch to
the right
for the foreseeable future and if things
seem hopeless right now
it's because to be completely honest
they basically are
this is a pivotal moment and what we got
here
a little bit by bad luck and bad timing
we also got here
through diligent effort by republican
leadership and crucially
some very big systemic problems which
just have to be
addressed so tonight let's talk about
that specifically
how the we got here and what the
we can possibly do next and there
are basically
two major factors that brought us to
this point the first
is this man mitch mcconnell the only
thing to come out of kentucky more
shameless
than the kfc menu how do you want your
chicken regular
crispy cheeto flavored in a warm slurry
as bread because it's all on the table
at kfc we promise
maximum flavor for you maximum
disrespect for a chicken's memory
reconfiguring america's courts has been
a single-minded focus for mcconnell
trump wants marvel's to bob woodward
that you know what mitch's biggest thing
is in the whole world
his judges and his obsession isn't just
with the supreme court
mcconnell's blockade of merrick garland
justifiably got a lot of attention but
he also
made sure that trump could stack the
lower courts with conservative judges
something trump
also explained to woodward i'm going to
be up to 280 judges very soon
nobody's ever had that 180.
obama gave us 142 judges yeah when i
came here
yeah it never happened you never had one
if you were a president
you would never have any federal you
know they're like golden nuggets right
okay first it's weird to refer to
anything as
golden nuggets unless you're talking
about actual golden nuggets or
you're describing your husband's balls
in the middle of his tiger-themed
funeral while impersonating a priest
those are the only two perfectly
appropriate times
but needless to say obama very much
didn't deliberately leave those
vacancies open for trump
when republicans took the senate in 2014
mitch mcconnell began systematically
blocking
lower court appointees so a future
republican president
could fill the seats later so obama
didn't give trump those judges
any more than the national archives gave
nicholas cage the declaration of
independence
in fact obama's only ever given trump
two things
a brief tour of the white house and a
colossal inferiority complex that fueled
trump's rise to power
and made him so furious he decided to
turn america into an apocalyptic
hellscape and destroy democracy as we
know it
really just those two things and
mcconnell's willingness to go to the map
for judicial appointments was perhaps
never more obvious than during the
kavanaugh hearings because
immediately after christine blasey
ford's gut-wrenching testimony
mcconnell apparently had this
conversation with the president
both of them were kind of testing each
other a little bit where are you at on
this you know how strong are you
and mcconnell basically says to the
president you don't worry about me i'm
strong as mule piss that's his quote i'm
strong as a mule piss
in other words he's not gonna let up
he's not gonna give up he's not gonna
surrender
wow that is extraordinary
because it's easy to forget that after
blasey ford's testimony
kavanagh's confirmation felt a lot less
certain
and to react to what she said with don't
worry i'm strong as mule piss
is both horrendous and deeply weird
quick side note
i wasn't sure how strong mulepis
actually is in the internet is
surprisingly short of videos
of mules urinating although we did
manage to find this stock footage titled
donkey who urine at sunset and i have to
say
that is an impressively strong stream so
i do
totally get it now and going forward
every time i think of mitch mcconnell
i will think of that donkey who you're
in at sunset
but as easy and fun as it is to blame
mitch mcconnell and his mule piss for
everything
it is a mistake to focus just on the
people involved here because
there is a whole system underneath them
that has enabled them to do what they
have done and that brings us to the
second major factor
that got us to where we are now the
deeply undemocratic nature
of america's institutions because there
is no doubt the republican party
currently controls both the senate and
the white house it's true
and they will argue that this gives them
a mandate to do exactly what they're
doing
chris the senate majority is performing
our constitutional duty and fulfilling
the mandate that the voter
voters gave us voters have elected a
republican president they've elected a
republican
senate and i think republicans need to
keep their promises here and that's what
i intend to do
the american people elected president
trump and a republican majority
because we want the constitution and
bill of rights protected
and that is our job it's what we need to
do i do not like that man ted cruz
i do not like his backward views i do
not like his stupid suits
i do not like his cowboy boots i do not
like him when he sneezes
i do not like him eating cheeses i hate
to see his dumb face smirking because
his beard
looks like a merkin but look let's talk
about
that mandate because neither the
presidency nor the senate are nearly as
reflective of the will of the american
people
as they are suggesting there first take
the white house
a democrat has won the national popular
vote in four out of the last five
elections but we've spent 12 of the last
20 years
with a republican in office and that is
because the electoral college with its
winner-take-all approach in most states
can distort the will of the majority on
top of which
it grants disproportionate power to less
popular states
which tend to be rural and more
conservative something which is even
more pronounced
in the senate where there are 15 states
representing 38 million people
that have 30 republican senators even
though that is less than the total
population of california
which has just two democratic ones and
that's before
you even get into the fact that places
like puerto rico and washington dc where
the populations are
largely black or hispanic don't have
representation in the senate
at all in fact if you take all of this
together the senate gives the average
black american only 75 percent
as much representation as the average
white american and the average hispanic
american
only 55 as much and it's clearly not
great
when the best thing you can say about
your representative democracy is hey
at least black people got above
three-fifths this time at this rate they
could count as 100
of a white person as early as 2408
onwards and upwards black people
you truly are an inspiration to hispanic
half people everywhere
so the fact is when barrett is confirmed
a president who lost the popular vote
will have picked a quarter of the
federal judiciary
and a third of the supreme court and his
choices will have been rubber-stamped
by a senate republican majority
representing 15 million
fewer people than the democratic
minority and if that sounds absurd to
you
it's because it clearly is especially
when
those courts have allowed republicans to
set wildly unpopular policy that
wouldn't actually pass muster with
voters
and that brings us to our final question
of what can now be done
well for democrats the first priority is
to try and take control of the white
house and both chambers of congress this
november which
given everything we've just discussed is
by no
means a certainty not only could trump
win the election outright even if he
doesn't
he could as he's repeatedly indicated
refuse to concede
and force the result into the courts and
that possibility is clearly part of his
haste
to get a justice confirmed before the
election because
he's not even trying to hide it now we
did nine justices
you need that with the
unsolicited millions of ballots that
they're sending it's a scam it's a hoax
everybody knows that
and the democrats know it better than
anybody else so you're going to need
nine justices up there i think it's
going to be very important
okay there is a number of dark
insinuations there including
it's important for us to choose the next
justice so they can decide
what the american people choose and that
makes it pretty clear that for trump
having an additional supreme court
appointment is absolutely
crucial to his re-election as crucial
say as
angry white people wearing red hats
facebook posts from undercover russian
operatives and
based on his campaign's online store
selling trump coloring books that even
the kids in the ad
look bored by what is going on there
the younger kid isn't even paying
attention and the older one looks like
he's trying to will the coloring book
into becoming a nintendo switch with his
eyes
also why aren't they coloring in the
coloring book
the father seems to be reading it to his
children which is objectively
the one wrong way to enjoy a coloring
book
but look let's say for the sake of
argument democrats do manage to sweep
the upcoming election the biggest
mistake
would be to think that that has in
itself fixed everything or indeed
anything because there is no point
getting power unless you're then willing
to be bold enough
to use it to make significant structural
change we've argued before that the
filibuster
should be abolished that would allow
legislation to get passed with a simple
majority it is
admittedly risky especially for a party
that again for structural reasons
can expect to be in the minority more
often than it should
but those very factors make it extremely
hard for democrats to win a
filibuster-proof
supermajority and do anything meaningful
what is frustrating is that some
centrist democrats like joe manchin
honestly seem to think that even if they
somehow significantly get more power
the best way forward is to try and
return to a more civilized
moderate era in american politics i will
make every decision i can
that keeps the senate bipartisan right
simply
so we've got to fight for basically who
we are as a senate
can we represent the people in a
bipartisan way democrats and republicans
oh i've got an answer to that question
for you joe no
you can't it seems the message manchin
would take from america
surging to the left against the odds
would be i think they want us to work
with the republicans
and that is not just dumb that's dumb on
the level of james cameron going you
know what people want
four more avatar movies and to both of
those men i say this
no one wants that stop talking about it
and just give us what we do want
one more good terminator movie and a
green new deal i don't care which of you
does which
just get it the done although i
will say
even if the democrats sweep the election
and even if they then get rid of the
filibuster
and then have the courage to pass major
legislation those laws are now
increasingly vulnerable to a more
conservative supreme court striking them
down
and that has led some to suggest taking
the more dramatic step
of expanding the supreme court by adding
justices
it is possible the constitution doesn't
specify how many seats there should be
and it can
and has been done in the past through a
simple act of congress although
there are real concerns about what the
eventual blowback to that
would be because it doesn't take a
genius to imagine what republicans would
do
next time they took control of the
government seriously
it doesn't take a genius they want to
pack the court you know that means they
want to put on a lot of
justices these are things that are just
horrible
i guess we could do that too right we
could do that too
yeah he's right he could absolutely do
that which is undeniably chilling
expanding the court is a bit like doing
yoga naked
one way to dampen your enthusiasm for
the idea is to picture donald trump
doing it too
court expansion could open the door to a
never-ending cycle of both parties doing
it which could permanently destabilize
one of the bedrock institutions of
american governments now does that
outweigh the potential for a court with
barrett on it
undoing or blocking years of protections
for our climate health care and civil
and women's rights
that is definitely worth considering
nothing should be taken lightly here
though i will say
there are some other steps we could take
that should be impossible to argue with
at this point
steps that would make both the senate
and white house more representative of
the electorate
on the senate side you could grant
statehood to washington dc
and if voters there wanted puerto rico
that would not only help balance out the
senate's bias toward white rural voters
it's also
the right thing to do for the
almost four million americans who
currently have no senatorial
representation whatsoever
which is just astonishing that's roughly
the population of rhode island maine
montana and wyoming combined
now as for the presidency we have to get
rid of the electoral college which might
sound radical
but it really isn't it's not even a new
idea
in fact in the late 60s it very nearly
happened here's birch bai
the senator who spearheaded those
efforts making what is in retrospect
a pretty convincing case there is a
great danger
with the present electoral college
system of electing a minority or a
non-plurality president
of electing a president who has fewer
votes than the fellow he's running
against
when we have an electoral college system
which threatens to elect a man who has
fewer votes than his opponent
we tend to erode the confidence in the
people of this country and their
president and in their form of
government
right and as someone who has lived
through the exact hypothetical he just
described
and twice i can report that our
confidence in government
hasn't so much been eroded erosion is a
slow dignified process
as much as it's been hit by an asteroid
full of sentient nuclear jackhammers
until it collapsed in on itself like a
star inside a black hole
back then the idea of abolishing the
electoral college had bipartisan support
then president nixon even urged congress
to go through with it writing
every four years the american democracy
places a large
unacceptable and unnecessary wager that
the electoral college will work one more
time
which does make sense because if there's
one thing we know nixon was not a fan of
it's leaving elections up to chance and
if there are six things we know he
wasn't a fan of it's
jews blacks hippies snitches living
vietnamese people and then
leaving elections up to chance miss you
dick
but obviously we didn't end up doing
away with the electoral college in 1970
because the legislation was ultimately
blocked by
you guessed it a filibuster
and even today the idea has widespread
support with
61 percent of americans saying we should
abolish the electoral college
but republicans will fiercely defend it
in fact when a movement to switch to a
national popular vote began picking up
steam a decade ago
mitch mcconnell said republicans need to
kill it in the cradle
before it grows up but the beauty is
the movement mcconnell was talking about
there doesn't necessarily require his
cooperation or indeed
an act of congress at all because a
group of states
have quietly signed on to an interesting
potential workaround
recently 15 states and the district of
columbia
joined the national popular vote
interstate compact
they're pledging to give their electoral
votes to the candidate who wins the
national popular vote
rather than the person who wins the
popular vote in their state
but this won't take effect until enough
states adopt it
which so far hasn't happened yeah
it's kind of amazing very basically if
enough states just pretend the electoral
college
doesn't exist it could functionally
disappear it's the same approach every
harry potter fan
is currently trying to take towards jk
rowling obliviate
you go the books stay now for this idea
to take effect
setting aside the legal hurdles it would
almost certainly face
it would need states representing 270
electoral votes
to sign on it currently has 196
which is a lot but need 74 more which
would be increasingly hard to get and
obviously
the better way to abolish the electoral
college would be to do it
through a constitutional amendment but
that is even harder and i will say
there are other ideas for significant
reforms such as setting term limits for
supreme court justices
which we've argued before we should
absolutely do
the point here is it is past time for
big change and perhaps that is why
republicans like kevin mccarthy
already seem to be freaking out the
democrats believe it has to be their way
or no way but now it's a new extreme
they want to expand the court
they want to bring new states into the
union anything that rigs the system on
their behalf
instead of believing in the rule of law
okay
first of all you kevin if there is
one group of people who don't get to
complain about their opponents going to
extremes to get what they want
it's congressional republicans
and secondly
we've expanded the court before and
we've added states before
we added two states in 1959 we didn't
fight world war
ii with 50 stars on the flag america is
constantly shifting and granting dc and
puerto rico statehood or
ending the electoral college would
actually make our system more democratic
rather than less because the unavoidable
truth here
is that the system is already rigged and
it's rigged in a way that has allowed a
party without popular support
to drastically reshape an entire branch
of government for the foreseeable future
by appealing almost exclusively to white
voters in some of the least populous
regions of the country
that is not a mandate and it's not
democracy
it's a travesty we're at the end
of a generational battle and the
heartbreaking thing
is we lost and that hurts
it's going to hurt for a long time for a
lot of people
in ways that could take a while to fully
comprehend
but the next battle has to start right
now and it will be long we didn't get
here overnight and we won't get out of
here overnight but we must be willing
to fight tirelessly and with every tool
and tactic at our disposal because
sometimes
fighting fire with fire is not enough
you have to fight mule piss
with mule piss